Every time we talk about how X or Y scenario
is likely to go forward during what is hopefully
the last 15 months of Donald Trump's presidency.
Those analyses assume that Republicans are
not going to turn on Donald Trump, that in
the end, Republican senators would not vote
to impeach Donald Trump, that Trump's Republican
cabinet would not use the 25th amendment to
try to remove Trump from power.
Those are the assumptions that we're operating
under.
However, former Trump white house communications
director, I think he lasted 10 days.
Anthony Scaramucci has a different perspective.
He now says that 20 or more Republicans are
set to turn on Donald Trump.
This is Scaramucci effectively predicting
a sort of Nixon like scenario from the 1970s
you might remember Republicans, a Weddington
Nixon in the 70s and the wake of in the, in
the midst of the Watergate fiasco and said,
listen, we don't want to impeach you, but
we're going to have to if it comes to a vote,
so why don't you resign?
And that's exactly what Richard Nixon did
check out Scaramucci on CNN making the case.
Well, you know, he obviously knows a lot more
facts about the case are going to unfold over
the next, you know, two to six weeks, Don.
And so I think that's got him rattled and
I think he's, he's also looking at the future.
The future does not look good for him because
as more facts unfold about Syria, as more
facts unfold about the people that have been
arrested recently and the conjoint of all
those issues over there, uh, it's going to
be devastating for the president and what
will ultimately happen, which I predicted
on CNN air two months ago.
Uh, the full blown meltdown we're experiencing
speaker Pelosi described it today, but will
eventually will eventually happen, is the
criminal activity will be so great that the
GOP, and there'll be 20 plus senators will
say, okay, I can't take this anymore.
Reminiscent of what Howard Baker and, uh,
Barry Goldwater did in the 70s and called
Richard Nixon and said, look, no Moss, you
gotta go.
And so that, that will eventually happen.
And that's the reason why he's pressurized.
But I really wish the white house press would
just ask him what was in it for him personally.
So this is just one guy, right?
I mean, this is just Anthony Scaramucci.
You never want to put too much stock into
what any one person says.
But this is a narrative that has been floating
around for awhile and the idea is actually
deeper than 20 Republicans will turn on Trump.
The real idea is a whole bunch of Republicans
have already turned on Trump in their minds
internally.
The question is that they are balancing their
own political futures with doing what they
believe is right, which is turning on Donald
Trump.
Now, this isn't a great moral realization
about Republicans.
Republicans who support Trump are immoral
and indifferent to supporting so-called conservative
values.
That's bad enough.
Republicans who privately don't support Trump
but continue to support them publicly, they
are also terrible.
They're merely choosing political expediency
in calculation for the benefit of their careers
over what they actually believe would be good
for the country, which is pretty damn bad
in a different way.
So when we hear Scaramucci say it, he may
know what he's talking about.
He may not.
It'll be interesting to see if and when it
happens, but to the extent that this is an
existing narrative that we've been following,
we just need to watch the polls.
Support for impeachment and removal has been
climbing.
If we believe that there are at least some
disgruntled Republican senators out of the
53 uh, that are currently in the Senate and
they're waiting around for public support
to be high enough that the risk to their careers
is diminished.
If they come out and say, it is time to remove
Donald Trump, we're pretty damn close to getting
there.
We have a support for impeachment and removal
hitting and surpassing 50% in a hyperpolarized,
modern status quo of American politics.
You're not going to get that much more before
it becomes tantamount to major support for
removing the president of the United States
from office.
And what we know is that these Republican
senators are all about just putting their
finger to the wind, trying to end up on the
right side of public opinion, conservative
so-called values.
Be damned so we don't even have to put any
special stock in what Anthony Scaramucci is
saying here.
This has been a possibility for awhile.
We've been considering it for about a year
and a half and we'll follow it.
There is a timing issue though as we are now
only um, 12 and a half months from the 2020
election, which is if Republicans are going
to turn on Trump, they sort of need to do
it pretty soon before it's going to be too
little too late.